good morning
good afternoon hi everyone my name is
jim park and i'm one of the senior
scientists from military sigma
today i would like to talk about our
microfluidic space
lasik life cell imaging platform which
offer precise
on-demand control over various cellular
environment
and says enable what we call dynamic
lifestyle
imaging
here's the outline of today's
presentation i'll briefly cover
two platforms that can enable creation
of more physiologically
relevant vitro systems then i will cover
the basics of dynamic lifestyle imaging
with brief intro to our celesix platform
which enable dynamic lifestyle imaging
with any existing
inverted microscopes main part of the
presentation today
will be applications demonstrating the
utility of cellulitic system
with particular emphasis given to
membrane-based
platforms
let's start with the background
information of physiologically relevant
in virtual systems
i think we're all aware that the current
tissue culturing method
as shown on the left side of the slide
does not reflect
many imbivo parameters such as change in
temperature
gas and flow of nutrients which can
all change and fluctuate inside our body
in addition growing cells on flat tissue
culture surfaces
does not resemble 3d spaces cells are
growing
in vivo
one of the most established way to
create more
in vivo like culture system is to use
micro porous membrane platforms
two examples are shown here upper images
show sertoli cells
and bottom images on the slide show caco
cells
in both cases we're comparing indicated
cells grown on tissue culture treated
plastic surface
compared to the microphorus microporous
membrane surfaces notice how cells grown
on membrane surfaces acquire
more in vivo-like morphologies with
well-defined
polarized physiology cells on plastic
surfaces
simply grow as a flat monolayer of cells
in addition in addition to men
in addition to membrane platforms there
is an increasing awareness
that microfluidics can create more
physiologically relevant culturing
system
when coupled with appropriate setups
microfluidics can offer
user-defined on-demand control
of cellular micro environment such as
temperature
gas and media proficient while enabling
continuous
life cell imaging we'll cover much of
the microfluidics
in today's talk
let's start with some background
information on dynamic life cell imaging
i think by now it is well established
that lifestyle imaging offer
tremendous biological insight over more
static imaging due to this skill and
temporal information
example let's take a look at the static
image in the middle of the slide
what you see in the middle of the slide
is a bunch of teal info sights
we should load it with the costume
indicator fluorescent dye
to simply put not much insight can be
gained
from such a static image perhaps other
than what appears to be
a different level of dioptake as in by
different fluorescent intensities
among the t cells
however if we are to take a time-lapse
image of these t-cells
as shown in the bottom of the slide we
start to gain deeper level of
understanding and awareness to the
spatiotemporal dynamics of the cells at
single cell level
in this particular experiment calcium
indicator loaded t
cells were kept without disturbance
indicated as a resting t
cells and then activated with ionomycin
which causes
increasing intracellular calcium level
very important
and key step in the activation of t
cells
while these are snapshots taken from
actual time-lapse image
already couple observations can be made
which were not possible
when we're just looking at the static
image in the middle of the slide
for example we start to notice that the
t cells are actually oscillating
in their calcium level even during
resting stage
and also that there is a significant
level of heterogeneity
among the t cells in terms of their
calcium responses
let's play the movie itself to better
appreciate what is going on
taken together dynamic live cellular
imaging offers
analysis of cellular events at single
cell level
thus enabling study population
heterogeneity
study of cellular biology as a function
of microenvironmental perturbation
for example we can study calcium
responses of t cells before
during and after their activation while
we'll control when and how
test agonists in this case ionomycin is
added
other common examples would be dynamic
gas control where cells grown under
non-moxic condition
are subjected to hypoxic condition and
then brought back to the moxie condition
and time-lapse images are taken under
these dynamic
conditions last but not least
is the time dimension where we can now
study various cellular responses
such as morphology movement and velocity
intracellular signaling as well as a
cell cell interaction
as a function of time to obtain
spatiotemporal information
of any given biological system
now let's take a bath up
now let's take a step back and think
about some of the challenges in terms of
building or buying a system
which will enable dynamic lifestyle
imaging dynamic life cell imaging
while it is very powerful tool has its
challenges uh this is an image from
wikipedia
and nicely demonstrate the complexity of
such a system
they're very large and complex systems
with high price tag requiring
well-trained scientists
to operate also in all cases
additional do-it-yourself components are
required
control perfusion and fluid capability
in order to create true dynamic imaging
system
these components such as pumps and
profusion chambers
with associated controllers will further
create complexity
and increase prices now i do want to
point out that they are
simplified version of such systems that
exist
uh however they're very still expensive
well over seventy thousand dollars
and also simpler systems tend to be
closed systems
uh with limited capability
switching gears then let's talk about
our celesic platform
what would be key advantages of our
system
to start it is a true turn key
product with the integrated
environmental control system
couple to microfluidics plate where
cells will be cultured
and imaged the system controller is the
size of a typical 13-inch laptop
in x and y dimension and apr to stack
four of these laptops it'll be
in height as well it is extremely
portable
and was built with the mobility in mind
the controller enables software driving
on demand control
of temperature gas and fluidics of the
plates
and so it's making dynamic lifestyle
imaging experiments possible
and it is connected to the plate via
vacuum
manifold software is extremely intuitive
and unable step-by-step protocol
building where each step can be built
with the user defined time temperature
gas and perfusion parameters such as
flow rate
the plate has standard 96 well footprint
image and center show one of our plate
preloaded with a color die
to show individual layout of the
fluidics
as you can see the plate is divided into
six inlet wells on the left side
and two outlet wells on right side
connected to the central tissue culture
chamber area
each of these inlet wells connected via
microfluidic channel
to the central tissue culture chamber
where cells are grown
and imaged and then there is an exit
channel
where waste and used media from the cell
chamber will be delivered
to the outlet wells
as you can see in this cartoon for each
raw
indicators of group one two three and
four
i'm gonna just repeat it again one more
time sorry
as you can see in this cartoon for each
row indicated as a group one
two three and four all the individual
well
within the group are connected to tissue
chamber
area via individual microfluidic
channels
which are colored lines this enables up
to four
independent experiments to be conducted
perpetually
when the plate is connected to the
controller via manifold
media or reagent in each of the inlet
wells
can be pressed down via positive
pressure
this will then move the media or reagent
from that well into the tissue culture
chamber area
and then we'll exit to the outer wells
essentially this creates a system where
any desired media
reagent can be precisely delivered to
cells in the chamber area
at desired time for specific duration
and with specific flow rate since the
plate can be temperature and
gas controlled we now have a system
that can be uh they can offer ability to
control cellular micro environment
in dynamic demand fashion
in addition the plate material is also
made of gas permeable polymer to allow
dynamic gas control
and the bottom of the plate is made of n
1.5 glass
for clear imaging including confocal
applications
a last thing i would like to mention is
that the since the
these are microfluidic plates we also
introduce
specific micro dimensional features that
can be used for certain applications
such as the imaging of suspension cells
or maintenance of chemotactic gradient
now let's move on to the main part of
the talk
our system can be connected to two
independent gas
outlets so in this example we can create
domoxic
and hypoxic conditions using gas
switching ability
the middle image shows fluorescent
intensity of reverse
oxygen sensor rtdp
which will decrease fluorescence with
the increasing oxygen
concentration and vice versa fluorescent
was measured from
the tissue culture chamber of our plate
while we change
gas compositions dynamically time is
indicated on the
x-axis rtdp for essence is indicated on
y-axis arrows indicates the time point
at which gas
switching was initiated as you can see
rtdt fluorescence increases as we put
tissue chamber under hypoxic condition
starting at t equals two hours you will
also notice when we put the tissue
chamber under normoxy condition
around t equals six hours fluorescence
starts to decrease
which we then switch back to normalcy
condition at around t equals
10 hours with ensuring increase in rtdc
fluorescence
the image on the right shows special
responses under hypoxic
and nomoxy condition by measuring
expression level of hephan alpha
which is a key transcription factor
under cellular hypoxia
rtdp fluorescence is indicating a blue
line as expected
as the cells are subjected to hypoxic
as seen by the black line and then later
on
as the cells are subjected to nomoxy
condition
we see fluorescence of rtd feed
decreasing
which in turn is followed rapidly by
decreased expression
of heatphone alpha we're also looking at
gap intensity as a control
in purple line and it shows no
meaningful change on their
changing oxygen levels
next we would like to show you the
lesson will be generated using biocheck
or hypoxia lifestyle dye
this is a cell permeable lifestyle dye
which becomes fluorescent under hypoxic
condition
inside of cells here we're looking at
a4c1 cells
loaded with and without dye after 16
hours incubation
under hypoxic condition to show its
specificity
now let's take a look at the live cell
movie
next we will look at the autophagosome
formation sorry
gotta say that again
next we will look at the autophasm
formation under hypoxia using
fluorescent lysosomal marker
lc3 under hypoxic condition cellular
stress will induce formation of a
punctate
autophasms and this can be visualized
and measured
based on life cell imaging let's take a
look at the movie
next applications uh we're looking at
intracellular trafficking of proteins
in this case we are examining
internalization of fluorescent egf
receptor
upon egf activation you'll notice upon
the addition of egf
the receptors uh start to collapse
together
which then gets internalized to
endoscope compartment
with characteristic punctate patterns
again let's take a closer look
with the lifestyle movie
now i want to cover perhaps one of the
most widely investigated cellular
behavior
which are migration and innovation
for this type of studies membrane
platforms are very widely used
in addition membrane platforms are well
characterized and established
for barrier models as well but this will
be covered
in later slides for now let's start with
migration and invasion applications
using membrane inserts
for these a poor size of the membrane is
critical
and in most cases eight micron pore size
is the most
commonly used ones
the difference between migration and
evaluation is really about the presence
of ecm gel matrix
if the acid is performed without ecm gel
in presence of chemotactic gradient then
it is a migration assay
if the acid is performed in presence of
ecm gel
then it is an invasion assay as cells
need to move through the ecm matrix
towards the chemoattractant in both
cases
directional movement of cells towards
the chemoattractant
can be measured simply by removing cells
or cells and ecm gels in case of the
invasion assay
from the top side of the membrane and
increasing cells on the bottom
side of the membrane
here are some example data generated
using 96 well mili cell plates
with 8.0 micron pore size
plot on the right side of the slide show
fluorescent intensity of the cells
from the bottom side of the membrane
after migration assay
for both plots cellular fluorescent is
plotted on
y axis plot on the upper left
shows the effect of serum concentration
on cellular migration
the concentration of serum use are
indicated
on x-axis plot on the lower left
shows up stop
mistake hold on yeah i'm gonna do this
one again cue
here are some example data generated
using 96 well middle cell plate
with 8.0 micron pore size plus on the
right side the spy
show fluorescent intensity on the cells
from the bottom side of the membrane
after migration assay
for both plots cellular fluorescence is
plotted
on the y-axis plot on the upper
right shows the effect of serum
concentration
on cellular migration the concentration
of serum used
are indicated on x-axis
the plot on the lower right shows
inhibitory effect of
rhd peptide on cellular migration
induced by
0.5 serum inhibitor concentrations are
indicated on x-axis
now for invasion assay which is
essentially 3d form of a migration assay
using ecm gel matrix there are some
couple key takeaways
when setting up the assays the bar graph
on the right shows
level of cellular invasion reflecting
the level of cells that
moved through the ecm matrix and were
present on the bottom side of the
membrane
you'll notice that concentration of ecm
gel
plays very critical role
it is very important to dilute the ecm
gel
to identify optimal assay concentration
if concentration of ecm gel is too high
then cells cannot invade through the gel
as the matrix is too hard and you will
get
pretty much zero signal from the cells
the concentration of ecm gel is too low
then there will not be enough matrix to
cause invasion
which indicates the assay will simply
become a migration assay
also consider that ecmgel itself also
contains chemoattractant
which can reduce signal to noise ratio
in this example best concentration would
be between 6
to 12 gels
while migration innovation is widely
performed
on membrane platforms they do not allow
live cell imaging for
for obvious reasons so here we now show
how
microfluidics can enable life cell
imaging of cellular migration
while maintaining chemo gradient
we have a microfluidic culture chamber
that is connected to
two parallel flow channels
cells are cultured in the middle chamber
and chemotractan is profused
onto an adjacent channel as you can see
in the images at the bottom
cell will migrate towards the presence
of chemoattractant let's take a closer
look
with the livestream movie
next i would like to cover life cell
imaging of suspension spells which pose
unique challenges
uh due to their non-observed nature as
you can see on the
image at the at the bottom left during
laxal imaging
suspension cells will move up and down
making it impossible to imagine cells at
single cell level
however if we introduce microfluidics
sealing
feature as shown by the cartoon on the
upper panel of the slide
then we can confine the cells under
single focal plane
and enable clear visualization of cells
doing
light cell imaging
for example we'll be able to maintain in
great detail
cell cell interaction of t cells with
that of
antigen presenting b cells these are
snapshots taken from a livestock movie
now let's take a closer look with live
movie itself
here's another example where we are
examining t cell autopsies at single
cell level
we're using cd95 activation to induce
program cell deaths
and then visualizing the cellular events
using caspase-3 specific autopsies probe
as well as annexin 5. let's take a look
at the lifestyle movie
i just want to cover a few more things
uh one of the long term
stop cut mark
i just want to cover a few more things
uh one of the uh
sorry stop
i just want to cover a few more things
uh one is a long-term culturing aspect
using microfluidics
since we are using very small volume of
media with continuous perfusion
we can culture cells for a very long
time tonight examples
are for 21-day neuronal culture on the
left and four-day culture
on the right
of course most established way to do
long-term culture is to use membrane
platform
let's take a look at 21 day caico
culture performed using plastic tissue
culture surface
versus 0.4 micron polycarbonate
you'll notice dramatic differences
between plastic surface and membrane
surfaces
with later producing cells resembling
in-vivo polarized morphology
let's take closer look using confocal
imaging
lastly i want to close off by going over
some 3d applications using ecm gel
cells can be loaded onto our
microfluidics plate with ecm gels and a
lot from 3d structures as shown on this
slide
we have a movies playing on the next
slide
now the summary and closing remarks
uh so in summary we have actually wide
range of plates
uh that specifically caters towards a
specific customer applications
our plates can be broadly divided into
mammalian plates
this can be identified the letter m in
the front
as well as we have a suit of plates that
are useful
for microbiology lifestyle imaging
applications as well
and these are shown on the lower right
part of this slide
we also enjoying growing list of
publications
our papers are very well cited in high
rank
prestigious journals currently we have
well over 700 provocations
citing our platform based on the google
scholar
key search
so in summary cellular biology is
complex
and it's dynamically changing in terms
of
microenvironment as well as its
responses
dynamic lifestyle imaging is an
indispensable tool therefore
to better understand these events uh
also
last but not least user microporous
membranes
enable creation of more relevant
in vitro culture systems
with that i would like to thank everyone
for today's webinar
if you have any questions please do not
hesitate to contact me
and our website uh simply just type in
sell lasik.com
and there you will be able to find a
much more information
once again thanks for your time
we are done
all right okay
oh my god the movies were okay
were the movies okay do the show okay
yeah
yeah they started off a little fuzzy in
the text at first
but um i think they were perfectly fine
because i mean i don't know maybe it's
my bandwidth or yours
not sure but they they cleared up
in time to understand what was happening
okay sure sure um yeah and tyler
i can also do quite a bit of editing
from my side as well as soon as you give
me your
mp4 file so some of the gaps and stuff i
can edit those as well
okay yeah that that sounds good
definitely um i made some
notes as well um so depend i can send
you a preview look and depending on if
you want to do
some of your some more of your own
editing then um you can let me know and
i can send that file over to you
yeah sure so what i prefer is probably
the finer version from your side
oh and when i look at it i can do the
final proof from my
side so uh please you know take it from
your side as far as you can
after i send you the slide without the
notes on them
definitely okay that sounds good all
right well um i hope to have the editing
done
um early next week for review and i'll
send that link over as soon as it's done
all right awesome great i'm ready um
oh go ahead all right
great job thanks so much really good
stuff okay okay thanks dean yeah
thanks everyone yeah thank you everyone
all right bye
okay take care bye